l'ylang bonjour et merci d'être heures
en direct avec nous sur rt france alors
sans surprise la pandémie a dominé les
premier échanges avec une avalanche de
déclaration une coordination au niveau
mondial est elle plus que jamais
nécessaire aujourd'hui pour faire face à
la situation actuelle
oui elle est évidemment nécessaire là
monsieur macro et les autres divisions
en font des tortues ouverte
il faut quand même rappeler que dans
cette affaire on a affaire à un problème
mondial on a affaire à un problème de
santé qui se pose de la même manière
dans tous les pays du monde et là aussi
gens font des portes ouvertes est donc
l'enjeu ce serait d'avoir un médicament
le moins cher possible parce que selon
les fournisseurs de médicaments
le prix annoncé en face selon les
fournisseurs de vaccins le prix annoncé
est extrêmement différent et évidemment
comme d'habitude hors de portée des pays
en développement et des pays du sud un
des sujets qui a également dominé les
discussions il est fière c'est la dette
des pays les plus pauvres on sait que la
semaine dernière les ministres des
finances du g20 ont convenu d'un cadre
groupe commun pour alléger cette dette
il implique notamment la chine et des
créanciers privés c'est mesure peut-elle
être vraiment une mise en place selon
vous alors si tout dépendra des détails
qui sont décidés moi je de toute façon
on a un problème global de tête on
insiste beaucoup d'ailleurs se troue sur
la dette publique parce que dans les
pays développés les dettes publiques en
soi quand elle est garantie par la
banque centrale n'est pas un problème on
va avoir un véritable problème de dette
privée
il va falloir absolument restructurer la
dette privée non seulement dans les pays
en développement mais aussi et surtout
dans les pays développés donc on a un
vrai problème de des privés il va
falloir prendre des solutions
courageuses
en matière de dette privée parce que
c'est la première cause de crise et si
on ne prend pas la chose à la racine et
au sérieux en mettant en place un plan
mondial
en ce sens on risque fortement de
connaître des crises à répétition dans
les années à venir
la dette privée la première cause de
crise économique
la question du financement des vaccins
aussi a été abordé on sait qu'il ya un
manque à combler de plus de quatre
milliards et demi de dollars pour sa
distribution à grande échelle
quelles sont les possibilités de
financement normalement on a affaire ici
par excellence à ce que les économistes
appellent un bien public c'est-à-dire à
quelque chose qui devrait être
accessible à toutes et à tous
gratuitement
étant donné que ces vaccins en grande
partie été financé sur des fonds publics
et bien à ce moment là il faut faire le
nécessaire avec des fonds publics pour
que les vaccins soient mises au point et
qui soit accessible à tous et à tous on
a un enjeu de santé publique ont un
enjeu qui mondiale le privé ne sait pas
gérer proprement ce genre de situation
le privé est évidemment là pour faire de
l'argent
on va pas faire de l'argent sur le dos
des pays africains des pays du judo ou
des pays en développement ont cessé mais
c'est pas possible donc il va falloir
gérer la chose j'en suis désolé avec de
la dette publique c'est pas une réponse
idéologique que je fais c'est une
réponse purement pragmatique on
n'arrivera pas à avancer si une partie
de la population mondiale et l'acsi nez
et une autre partie ne l'est pas on à
financer massivement les laboratoires
privés dans cette affaire on a mis des
fonds publics
maintenant il faut que les laboratoires
privés acceptent eux aussi de réduire
les marges qu'ils entendent faire sur
les vaccins vous allez vite selon les
laboratoires privés les les prix des
vaccins annoncés sont extrêmement
différents extrêmement 10 heures à
partir du moment où il ya des fonds
publics il faut accepter que les marges
soient beaucoup moins importante alors
en toile de fond ce sommet la victoire
de joe biden
la présidentielle aux états unis elle
l'arrivée du président élu est prévue
pour le 20 janvier
est ce que cette période de transition
aux états unis risquent justement
d'empêcher des prises de décisions sur
le long terme
normalement les de transition aux états
unis comme dans tout les grands comme
dans tous les grands pays démocratiques
si lisez ce fonds se font doucement le
problème c'est que ici c'est que
monsieur tron ne veut pas partir
spontanément du pouvoir qui refuse la
mise en oeuvre de cette transition
ce qui promet peut-être demain une
transition extrêmement difficile avec
une administration qui va reprendre le
relais qui note qu'il n'a pas les clefs
du pouvoir alors que c'était une trace
on doit agir vite dans un pays quand
même qui en matière sanitaire à cause de
son système de santé privé est
définitivement un pays du tiers-monde je
ne nie pas un pays en développement mais
un pays du tiers monde
vous savez que le système de santé
américain le plus cher du monde il est
aussi le moins efficace
il est réservé à quelques-uns donc ça ne
fonctionne pas très bien il faudrait
très très vite que la nouvelle
administration puisse prendre les clés
les choses en main pour pouvoir gérer
proprement cette pandémie et la mise en
place du vaccin s'il s'avère efficace
or pour l'instant cette transition se
fait très difficilement
merci beaucoup d'années langat d'avoir à
répondre à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes économiste maître de
conférences à l'université paris xiii et
membres des économistes atterrés